this kid is electric he is a delight to
watch and I speak on behalf of all
oklahoma sooners fans and they thank
their football Lords for this guy
certainly after Baker Mayfield did what
he did last year and now this young man
is up for the Heisman Trophy he's up for
the Maxwell and Davey O'Brien Awards
tonight he was named the AP college
football player of the year taking on
Alabama on the college football playoff
semifinal and he's also the hope for
many love the Oakland A's as well he is
Kyler Mari how are you caller I'm doing
fine what is life like for you these
days ah little hectic but I'm you know
I'm enjoying all of it
taking in one day at a time I mean this
is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
so I'm just just take it all enjoy all
right dinner circuit is that what you're
on right now pretty much for the dinner
circuit right now
no you're going for the award show
tonight and you've got the the Davey
O'Brien the Maxwell Award
how much have an influence has Baker
Mayfield been for you
Kyler um no not only was he an influence
on the field using insulin talking field
uh you know being ever good friends you
know kind of kind of similar stories a
little bit you know each from Texas up
in Texas so you're really the biggest
thing for me I think we're just sitting
back and just being on observe and watch
you know watch how it's done obviously
you know me being a big-time recruit
coming out of high school you know not
having the most successful season as a
freshman I think it was good for me to
actually you know you know God was
telling me to sit down take some time
and just you know mature and I think you
know you know being able to watch him as
part of the reason one basically you
know where I'm at right now well what
did you learn by watching them just just
how to do things you know just how to
play plan to play at this level I mean
the game changes obviously players get
better you know you gotta learn how to
watch them you learn how to you know
study for opponents you know how to play
the game at this level
calamari here
the Rich Eisen show how as being a
baseball player made you a better
football player coward yeah baseball I
would say I'd say just learn how to deal
with failure obviously you know I
haven't dealt with a lot of failure when
it comes to football but the figure that
I have dealt with um I think baseball's
prepared me for that it's a game of
failure you failed happen you know more
than half the time and I think anybody
who's played both or you know has played
baseball in place we'll all understand
that you know you can take some of that
stuff over you know a translates to the
to the game of football so and how is
being a football player made you a
better baseball player I guess I just
the mentality of it you know I don't
know I was I was kind of raised with
that with that mentality of uh
you know go hard and whatever I'm doing
um you know whatever it is work hard try
to be the best at it but I don't know
they're totally two different or two
totally different games but baseball is
way different football so I don't know
if there's you know I don't know if
there's anything that I really you know
takes from football great over baseball
it's interesting how one way you say
that there's definitely one that you
could take over from one of the sport
together and you say there's not much
from one of the other how about the fact
that maybe you don't get hit yeah you
didn't baseball I got hit quite a bit
season but uh yeah no it's definitely
nice not yet you know physically uh be
hit with a baseball you mean is that
what you're saying are you crowding the
plate Tyler is that what you're saying
um if you've ever seen me play you know
that yeah I mean my coaches had me back
off the place no yeah I bet I bet so
where does that decision stand right now
for you baseball and football you've got
a big choice coming up in the next few
weeks
yeah one at a time obviously uh right
now my my decision is to go play
baseball like I said I'm just taking one
day at a time like I mean I'm enjoying
this week like I said a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
and yeah bonus he
entirely possible though Cuyler that you
report to the A's having already also
two weeks before told the NFL that
you're available for the draft as well
just to keep your options open is that a
feasibility I have no III don't I'm
sorry I don't have it I haven't
discussed any of that I don't know okay
how many of that word no no I'm
seriously I'm it's interesting how so
your mindset right now you are not
looking over the steering wheel at at
decision dates in January and report
dates in February so you're saying yeah
no one - solely on you know this team
and you know what we have in front of us
okay and what do you have in front of
you calamari obviously I mean we you
know we put ourselves in a great
position to you know go out here in the
college football playoffs and placed a
good good Alabama team I mean we you
know when in the Big Show championship
last week was you know a goal that you
know this team set out in the beginning
a year is to stand it here at Oklahoma
you know for us I mean just we're right
we want to be and you know we're looking
forward to it and what is your
relationship with - oh if you have any
I've never met I've never met - is that
right so tonight will be the first time
you meet - you think no okay are you
gonna stare them down I mean what what
you got a plan here when you see him I'm
so yeah it's nothing it's nothing okay
yeah we're just we're just hanging out
and enjoying this week so there will not
be a Deontay Wilder Tyson Fury moment
when the two of you see each other
tonight all right and where were you
when you when you were waiting word
about whether Oklahoma was gonna get in
can you walk me through that process
where were you yeah actually I was I
woke up it was a long ago obvious you
know with the day before we won the Big
Ten championship so you know a little
long night got to sleep in we didn't
have a watch party or anything like that
so I was in the bed I was in the bed
when I found out and you know I just I
was I knew it came on at 11 o'clock
special time so I turned on the TV
and you know they're talking about they
were talking about George and all the
stuff a little a little
I wasn't obviously you know it wasn't
secure that we were getting in so you
know there's a little nerve-wracking a
little bit but you know I had a good
feeling that we were gonna get in and
yeah we did so like I said it's a great
opportunity for us what would it mean to
win the Heisman for you Tyler I've said
it multiple times you know growing up as
a kid you know watching college football
you know watching all the great to play
the game it'd be a great honor to be you
know be a part of such a prestigious
award another beer you know it mean a
lot to me my family my teammates just be
a great honor okay and last thing for
you I've got a scouting report for you
at the next level by daniel jeremiah of
the NFL network are you interested in
hearing at calamari go ahead okay here
we go
he said he's exciting to watch
definitely worth exploring NFL options
with an NFL arm based on what I've seen
what do you think of when you hear
something like that you ha ha ok he's
exciting to watch he says he hasn't
watched much of your film yet he calls
Chargers games but definitely worth
exploring NFL options based on what I've
seen and he thinks it's that that the
your arm is NFL quality caller I don't
disagree with ok alright look look look
I don't want to put you on viously
you've got a lot of exciting stuff right
here in front of you and and I'm just
wondering do you have any part of you
like sitting you're thinking you know
what I'd love to see what the NFL has to
offer to me I just wonder if I'm seeing
you at the combine in Indianapolis on
the NFL Network in February or March and
then last thing for you is is how did
they photograph of you mimicking the bo
Jackson
pose with the bat and the pads come
about yeah I I'm not for sure on who
brought it up around the facility but I
know it came from I came from obviously
you know somebody in the facility
you don't had the idea that you know
this kid you know he's doing well
football and baseball you're doing at a
high level so you know it was kind of
just it was a fun deal for me to do you
know pay homage stood you know arguably
one of the best athletes ever touched
this earth so yeah it was a great honor
to be able to do that it was fun I think
the picture turned out good it did you
know I mean you're pretty close in the
and the bow rip Department their collar
I didn't be honest with you so not my
back there Jonases yeah he's a freak
well Kyler thanks for calling in I've
really enjoyed watching you play
Oklahoma fans obviously feel much much
respect for you and good luck in all of
the awards sessions against Alabama and
whatever decision you do make I'd love
to chat with you anytime you bet the
Kyler Mari is his twitter handle at the
Kyler Marie the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience